I believe that he and Monica had a real
love affair I don't believe that he was
just using her my name is John Gartner
I'm a psychologist I teach part-time at
Johns Hopkins and i'm the author of in
search of bill clinton a psychological
biography
people who have a hypomanic temperament
is I think Bill Clinton does have
tremendous amount of energy creativity
they don't need much sleep they're very
charismatic but they're also way outside
the box and that can be good in terms of
their creativity but they also have
difficulty containing their impulses so
Bill Clinton has he eats too much he
blows up too much as reckless sex
possess things he shouldn't say but he's
also a change agent in a lot of ways so
he makes things happen but not always
the right things
when he was 8 years old his parents were
basically partiers I mean they were out
drinking and carousing and they weren't
church people and when he was eight
years old he started walking to church
by himself he would put on a tie walk a
mile carrying a big heavy Bible and the
pastor said every time he opened the
doors Bill Clinton is literally sitting
on the steps waiting for the doors to
open so I think he's always been a
seeker he's always been someone who sort
of seeking this kind of higher purpose
all these 80 year old people time yet oh
well Virginia Clinton now she had so
many affairs while she had affair with
this woman she had an affair with that
one so that one so to surprise me to
find out that in fact his promiscuity he
comes by it rightfully that she was
somewhat of a hypomanic temperament and
she was basically modeling a lot of
serial adultery for him I guess the
other thing that was surprising because
I found out that the person is supposed
to be his biological father may not be
as biological father there's always been
these rumors around Bill Clinton that
bill Blythe was not actually his father
and it's been written about another
biographies but mostly as rumors and I
went to hope and actually started
talking to people and as it turns out
this is so funny cuz i grew up in new
york city i don't know the psychology of
small towns but there are secrets and
small towns that everybody knows about
that nobody outside the town knows about
well within hope Arkansas it's kind of a
known it's believed to be a known open
secret that that was a legitimate I
think the other thing that was
surprising is I didn't realize how
incredibly smart Bill Clinton really is
we all know he is smart but he actually
in that southern kind of awestruck scan
away actually under States how smart you
know some people try to show they're the
smartest people in the room and actually
Brooklyn often is the smartest person in
the room and doesn't always display it
but people would talk about how he has
total recall how he reads everything
synthesizes everything and as Total
Recall for people that's the thing every
single person I met said I got to tell
you this story Bill Clinton met some
friend of mine you know five years ago
and he ran into him in the supermarket
said Joe how you doing how's your dog
blimpy you know when Woodward wrote a
book about the Clinton White House
called the agenda he talked about how
chaotic the Clinton administration was
and that's kind of what we saw this
chaos and all these people arguing and
disagreeing and leaking but the people
who I talked to who were actually part
of those negotiations around the budget
and that the Woodward wrote about in the
agenda said it was an exciting process
it was creative it was enlivening it's
true the meetings went on all night and
they were food
they were exhausted their passing out
but they described as being one of the
most vital times in their life you know
that was very creative and they really
went through the federal budget line by
line and really understood it mastered
it and so that kind of what looks from
the outside like a kind of chaotic
process ash and the inside was a
creative process and I think bringing
that to government you know hypomanic
creativity which is something I know a
lot about bringing that to government
was really kind of an amazing sort of
happening we don't the last time I think
we saw something like this was basically
Teddy Roosevelt I mean Teddy Roosevelt
was the last kind of hypomanic genius
president that we had who read all night
he you know just two opposed everyone
with his own zany brilliant ideas and
this is really an unusual sort of person
to have in the presidency
right now the economy we're in an
economic crisis we did have a period of
prosperity under Clinton I it wasn't
just an accident I mean Alan Greenspan
in his book about the economy can't say
enough about what Bill Clinton did for
the economy because he's a believer in
balanced budgets and Bill Clinton did
something very atypical I mean he was a
Democrat who decided to do something
very fiscally conservative and balanced
the budget and he did it and it had a
tremendous impact on the economy and
every economic figure that number was
supposed to go up went up and every
number that was to go and went go down
went down then Bush came in record
deficits the tax cuts didn't work we're
in the toilet and I think what we need
to do is go back to some of those
economic policies
first of all I think some of the proof
is in the pudding I think looking at
what he accomplished I might talk about
peace and prosperity he was an amazing
peacemaker you know Northern Ireland I
mean to talk about a quagmire he
actually convinced these people to make
peace I mean there's a moment in the
town square in Belfast where he makes a
speech that brings 70,000 people in the
town square Catholics and Protestants
for the first time ever in one place and
they start spontaneously singing silent
night in response to Sweden he elevated
the rhetoric to that level where he got
them you know and that's inspirational
and he did try to use it for good yes
okay he had affairs but even there by
the way I just do want to say one thing
about the relationship with Monica that
I think a lot of people don't appreciate
I think it is important and evaluating
his character I believe that he and
Monica had a real love affair I don't
believe that he was just using her and
there are several things that support
the first of all she wrote a memoir
about it and he would be in tears
sometimes when he was separated from her
for 12 months they had no sexual contact
all he called her three times a week and
ironically he was very conflicted about
it because he does love Hillary and the
first time he allowed himself to have an
orgasm with her was after the relation
been going for 14 months and she was
wearing a blue gap dress that was that
that was the blue gap dress that was the
incident so this was a real relationship
and what's interesting is that's
actually pretty typical of the way Bill
Clinton has a fair so I spoke another
woman who had affairs with him and they
are still in love with him and what's
interesting is his chief of staff that's
he right said because he told monarchy
had hundreds of affairs and his chief of
staff Betsy right who knows a lot about
his affairs said well look all these
right-wing operatives came to Arkansas
trying to dig up the dirt Bill Clinton
and none of them got anything except for
Jennifer flowers so either he didn't
have the affairs or all the women they
had affairs with her still loyal to him
now obviously had the affairs so it
means that they are still loyal to him
it means that he's not just a cat he
really forms these meaningful love
connections but he's capable and wired
such that he does it with more than one
person which is different than just
being you know a CAD who uses people and
discards and has contempt for them which
is the way he's been portrayed I don't
think that's fair
you